yes she is she has 90 days that's
amazing and I couldn't be more thankful
or more proud of her because addiction
being a disease it's work you know you
know that it's not an easy art it's very
hard it's not easy and there are no
shortcuts Demi Lovato's mom diana de la
garza sharing the good news this week
that demi is three months clean after a
reported drug overdose back in July we
just didn't know for two days if she was
gonna make it or not right I just feel
like the reason she's alive today is
because of the million millions of
prayers that went up that day when
everybody found out what was happening I
I don't think she would be here if it
hadn't been for those prayers and the
good doctors at Cedars Sinai and they
were the best I couldn't have asked for
a better team of people to save her life
[Music]
following her release from the hospital
demi entered a rehab facility to further
her treatment this demi doing all right
yes yeah yes
no dummy's doing she's doing really well
she's working really hard on her
sobriety and we're also incredibly proud
of her it's been and it's been crazy for
our family it's been a lot but we've
been through a lot together now a source
tells ET Demi plans to stay in treatment
through the end of the year
quote Demi is doing it really well and
is taking her sobriety extremely serious
and knows she has a long road ahead of
her continuing it Demi is thankful she's
still alive and is doing whatever she
can to never get to that point again
it's about my old self and breaking up
with my old self and my addiction and my
alcoholism it's just about you know not
going back to those old ways that I
always resorted to because it doesn't do
it for me anymore our source adds quote
at the end of the day Demi is doing this
for herself she asked to stay sober for
her but every time she has family or
friends visit her it reminds her of all
the other important people in her life
that she needs to fight for as well
sometimes say I just look back and I'm
just grateful to be alive
you know together are able to help other
people which in turn makes me feel
really great and you know I'm able to
look at my what I've done and I do kind
of like sit there and think well I'm so
glad that I got sober and I'm able to
help you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]